[Musique]
entretiens politiques avec arnaud
péricard maire de saint germain en laye
bonjour arnaud péricard bonjour alors
vous êtes maire depuis 2010 est vous
avez été très largement réélu il ya un
nom depuis 2009 saint germain en laye et
a fusionné avec four que d'ailleurs vous
êtes donc le maires des deux villes et
puis il ya un maire délégué de fourqueux
alors saint-germain naturellement c'est
une ville d'histoire c'est la ville de
louis xiv
c'est aussi deux villes de patrimoine
avec le château avec le musée
d'archéologie avec le musée maurice
denis
mais c'est aussi une ville un peu
populaire on pourrait dire avec la fête
des loges ya aussi psg au camp des loges
hier et puis une ville très innovatrice
avec sciences po sur l'université et
vous n'êtes créer un pôle universitaire
de design au fond j'ai envie de vous
demander qu'est ce que n'a pas su faire
le relais saint germain en laye vous
l'avez rappelé à beaucoup d'atouts et je
pense qu'il est important dans le monde
qui est le nôtre de se voit là de se
tourner de préparer au mieux l'avenir
alors il ya des sujets qui sont
importants on est dans un nom qui est
continuellement en effet référence en
bouillonnement en mutation et leur
commerce est tout d'abord de veiller à
prenantes ici bien toutes ces mutations
pour préparer au mieux et ferrand
l'avenir et faire en sorte que le cadre
de vie puissent non un peu détériorée
continuer à s'améliorer et puis surtout
vous l'avez rappelé veiller à un
équilibre
vous avez justement ap7 particularisme
c'est particularisme local que nous
avons entre la dimension patrimoniale et
la dimension populaire
c'est un gamin c'est aussi 20 3 %
d'augmentation
c'est un équilibre un très fort entre
tous types de population entre beaucoup
d'internationaux beaucoup de aussi de
d'habitants qui sont là depuis depuis
depuis très longtemps et donc heureux
derrière c est aussi d ir cet équilibre
là et moi je me définis un peu comme ça
je suis le garant d'un équilibre un
petit peu particulier alors vous avez
avec les pros avec une avance pour
demain avec le renforcement du pôle
santé qui est quelque chose qui est qui
est très important pour nous là quelques
saint germain là à saverdun a beaucoup
de choses de saint germain veut
continuer forge présent sur sur ses
points forts je dis souvent des petits
il faut qu'on soit fort sur nos points
forts c'est vrai que l'on pourrait
penser comme ça que le maire de saint
germain aurait plutôt tendance à
conserver la grandeur et l'histoire et
vous vous vous battez justement pour la
rénovation notamment de certains
quartiers je pense au quartier de
l'hôpital
est ce que vous pensez justement qu'une
ville qui ne bouge pas et une ville qui
se condamne ni complètement je pense que
l'immobilisme est un et 1 est une forme
est une forme de suicide par don
d'utiliser 7,7
cette imagerie je pense que toutes les
villes sont condamnés à bouger et elles
le sont d'autant plus qu'on ne voit
aller avec le recul que nous donnent les
les douze ou treize mois sur cette crise
sanitaire on voit bien que les villes
moyennes saint germain c'est un petit
peu moins de 50000 habitants
la 3d petit du département c'est une
ville moyenne à l'échelle des villes de
france pourrait bien qui a une gueule un
regain
réactivité pour ces villes moyennes ou
détriment peut-être des fortes
concentrations d forte densification
d'habitacle nous avons notamment paris
et en proche couronne et donc on doit
être au rendez vous de ces nouvelles
attentes on a une population 45% de la
population change tous les dix ans donc
on a des populations qui sont en attente
tout le temps de damon à tanger où tu
n'es pas de trois exemples sur les plus
pensé il ya un an et demi que l'inox
dans les cantines allait être un vrai
sujet mais pas et je le vois pas ce que
les parents nous ont sévi et la question
de l'alimentation et de la manière dont
cette alimentation est conditionnée de
repentir ça devient un vrai sujet qui
aurait pu penser que les vélos cargo il
ya un manque de temps allait être un
réfugié partage de l'espace public
les personnes ont convenu qu'il faut
constamment s'adapter
il faut constamment essayé de répondre à
ces à ces nouveaux besoins pour pas une
inflationnistes il faut pas non plus
faire du clientélisme est possible à
chaque fois de poser des équilibres
voilà avec seydou les pratiques ces
nouvelles devant ces nouveaux services
qu'il nous faut organiser dans notre
ville emma peel au service public
alors il ya évidemment dans ce peintre
entre histoire et et et d'innovation
entre le passé l'excellence et au par
les sciences po évidemment sciences po
saint germain et puis il ya ce cette
création du pôle universitaire
internationale tournée vers le vert le
design et l'innovation vous venez de
signer
quel encore c'est une forme de voile à
de regard vers l'avenir
enfin d'autres entre justement cette
histoire et l'avenir
on est dans un département qui quand
même
vieilli les chiffres sont là la
démographie est là et je crois que notre
rôle sur saint germain c'est de faire en
sorte pour y contribuer sur un
glissement à travers la présence
notamment une d'une force étudiante et
d'un enseignement supérieur
c'est quelque chose qui est un peu
bricolé sur sur saint germain et
sciences po a été un petit peu le
révélateur limon airs et jusqu'à preuve
du contraire allez peut-être 1500 2000
étudiants supérieur que ce soit des ptf
des bta avec classe préparatoire on
l'avait un certain nombre
d'enseignements qui existaient notamment
dans l'analyse et la particularité de
notre ville c'est que c'est la première
comme ignoble à la première communauté
pédagogique du département il ya
vingt-deux 2022 1500 élèves à saint
germain il ya dix lycées des collèges en
apparaît donc plus qu'à versailles alors
que la ville est est plus petit et c'est
aussi ça le le fruit de de cette
histoire pédagogique et d'autre on a
peut-être plus de responsabilités
supplémentaires
et puis sciences po est devenue là
dessus ça complètement transformer et
révolutionner un petit peu notre vie et
aujourd'hui on a un partenariat
privilégié notamment avec l'université
de cergy pontoise
alors on à cette première cette première
implantation donc de cette école de
design sous l'égide de l'université
pourquoi ces 500 étudiants on a débattu
lors qu'ils viennent également
s'implanter on a un doublement des
effectifs de sciences po qui ont passé
peut-être de 750 à mille cinq cents
élèves on a une école autour de de
l'inclusion qui doit qui doit arriver on
des partenariats avec les écoles
diocésaine c'est très important dans le
département
notre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
qu'à la fin de ce mandat nous passions
de peut-être 2000 à 5000 étudiants sur
saint germain 10% de la population et
d'en faire aller après saint-quentin
peut-être le deuxième pôle estudiantin
de 242 2 pdb en plus à berlin vous
l'avez rappelé sir us et bars et cafés
voilà c'est une ville qui se débine au
monde au monde étudiant c'est une ville
pour les étudiants vont apprendre à
aimer à découvrir alors un mot de la
situation sanitaire vous êtes de votre
partie de ces maires qui se sont
beaucoup battus notamment pour la
vaccination vous fait aussi partie des
maires qui sont consultés par le
président de la république emmanuel
macron avant avant qu'il prenne ses
décisions
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que au
fond les élus locaux parfois réussi à
suppléer au manque de l'est pas et
qu'ils ont plutôt bien fait oui c'est
une réalité moi j'étais surpris à 10
mois parce que vous l'avez rappelé est
élu en 2007 un jeune l'herbe peut-être
avec le moins d'expérience que même que
mes collègues mais moi j'attendais
beaucoup de l'état l'un dernière et
j'attendais et je n'ai rien vu venir
dans le sens où je suis pas vu des
camions de logistique à rêver avec des
masques avec des tests etc et les
chaussons sont différentes aujourd'hui
et je pense que peut-être si nous les
élus nous n'avions pas pris suffisamment
conscience de cette décentralisation et
donc de ce transfert
responsabilités et je pense que nous
n'avons peut-être pas su davantage de
responsabilités ça fait perdre la crise
et puis maintenant
la crise nous a de toutes les manières
par donner d'autre choix que de prendre
nos responsabilités et on l'a fait et on
s'est battu alors effectivement les
tailles dans l'idée on le voit on a
demandé aux agences régionales de santé
de gérer une crise pour laquelle elles
ne sont pas armés et ne s'est pas leur
métier des agences régionales de santé
elle gère des autorisations et
logistique n'ont pas de moyens humains
elles ont pas de camion et ça nous nous
les avons nous avons les ressources
humaines nous avons les ressources
matérielles et ça c'est quelque chose
qui change et peut-être patrice carmouze
si vous me le permettez l'un des
enseignements que moins de tirs c'est
que cette compétence en matière de santé
publique
elle ne va dorénavant être partagées
avec les acteurs publics
c'est un enseignement sans vouloir
polémiquer on le sait ça sens et c'est
compliqué la gestion de cette crise
c'est un petit peu pardonnez-moi
dépression trivial peu l'univers de la
démerde toi il faut se débrouiller
c'est ce que l'on fait c'est ce que la
plupart des villes le font et elles ne
font vraiment remarquablement bien et la
continuité tout ça et là des
enseignements ce qui va falloir voilà de
continuer à être en responsabilité sur
ces questions santé publique - j'ai créé
un conseil local de la santé avec les
médecins de ville avec l'hôpital de
saint germain poissy avec beaucoup
d'acteurs de la santé pour justement de
cadrer au mieux nos interventions
la menace est l'un des grands
enseignements de cette crise prosodie
oui c'est vrai que oui la crise va nous
aider nous oblige à réfléchir une
nouvelle et une meilleure peut-être
répartition des des pouvoirs alors eh
ben côté on reparlera avec grand plaisir
de saint-germain-en-laye avec vous merci
infiniment arnaud péricard bien films
africains
[Musique]